historians that Anthony Selden is with
us now he's the author of Johnson at 10
a biography lifting the lid on the
former prime minister's time inside
dining Street high it's good to see you
um he's fizzing at the moment for all
sorts of reasons Boris Johnson how's he
going to be feeling about this one do
you think
well he's obviously worried isn't he
which is uh uh sensible because he has a
lot to be worried about he did not run
the country well he was I think without
any question the worst prime minister of
the last 100 years and he was in charge
at the time of the worst epidemic for a
hundred years the public many of whom
suffered many of whom lost people have
the absolute right to know what happened
there's no precedent here and if the
judge baroness Hallett is calling for it
if it's blocked it will just lead to
endless interminable protests about
let's get to the truth at last so let's
get to the truth give her give the
Judiciary what they want and let's get
to the bottom of it and I don't think
it's going to be pretty that is exactly
why yeah they're trying to stop it there
is precedent uh looking back at the
chilcott inquiry
um they when that inquiry started it was
announced that the committee would be
able to request any British document and
call any British citizen to give
evidence but times have somewhat moved
on since then what that means that you
know maybe conversations that you might
have face to face you're now typing
quickly on your phone and if we don't
protect those sort of conversations
between ministers maybe they won't be
talking as much as they should during a
crisis in future or maybe Kay they will
be acting uh with decorum at judgment
and integrity so there'll be nothing for
them to be ashamed of when they become
open look in today's society everything
is open pretty much even 30 years ago
the cabinet secretary told me that
everything talked about in cabinet was
in the first edition of the evening
standard that was 30 years ago this is
just simply not acceptable
the judge in charge of the choir inquiry
has to find out the covert story was so
serious Boris Johnson was such a
reprehensible prime minister so anarchic
the cabinet secretary new in post put in
at the request of the prime minister's
Chief aide who himself was totally
anarchic we can't go back to this kind
of government there's no precedent here
because it was so unprecedented to have
a prime minister like Boris Johnson and
a chief aide the Prime Minister more
powerful than any Chief Aid in history
and it's such a sensitive time we need
to find out exactly the truth of what
went on at the public needs and deserves
to know they are public servants paid
for by the public let's get to the
bottom of it and then after that all
this is over that might be the time to
think about new ground rules but for the
moment absolute disclosure is the very
least the public deserve
how damaging might it be for the
reputation of somebody like Boris
Johnson who finds himself in a position
where an inquiry a Judicial inquiry that
he is set up when he was prime minister
is now threatening to sue because they
can't access documents that he has
I don't think that Boris Johnson's
reputation can go much lower than it is
at the moment I think that most members
of the public uh know that Boris Johnson
was a liar know that he was not fit for
purpose he didn't have the Integrity or
the skills or the judgment to run this
great country least of all at a time of
such crisis so I don't think that it
will sink much lower I think that if the
Prime Minister really is intent as he
said on cleaning up at the country after
at the mass of three years of Boris
Johnson then I think it's very clear
what the Prime Minister needs to do here
we need to find out the truth exactly
what happened and then people will know
and we can then move on we're not going
to move on till we get to the truth
we're looking at the truth till we get
the documents we're not going to get get
the documents if these excuses are put
up
those that support Boris Johnson are
saying this is just a yet another
attempt to tarnish His Image he's
already paid with his job it should stop
now
but they would say that wouldn't they
but they are a diminishing number of
friends let's remember that he did win a
landslide in December 2019 his MPS his
cabinet ministers were behind him and
one by one when they discovered what he
was like as I did talk about in that
book Johnson at 10 one by one uh they
abandoned him because they thought he's
simply for all his undoubted uh skills
his optimism uh his Good Humor his
occasional oratory uh he was not fit or
honest enough to be worthy of the very
distinguished and Noble job of being
prime minister so they abandoned him he
has fewer and fewer friends left and I
think at the end of this the number will
be even smaller